[Music]
i told you a remarkable story last week
about the man that nancy pelosi has
picked to lead a quote
security review of the capital complex
following the january
sixth riot there he is an unbalanced and
openly partisan general called russell
honore
within days of january 6th honore went
on television to announce without any
evidence whatsoever
that the capitol police had somehow been
part of a conspiracy
and helped the rioters get inside the
capital complex on purpose
and they allowed their buddies in
yesterday and they destroyed
a good portion of our house so they they
had help
inside the force and you could assume
about 30 percent of that force
support the guy in the white house
that's just the demographics
and he went on and on and on and on if
if you want to know what this is really
about the response to january 6 go on
the internet and search his name
his greatest hits will let you know this
has nothing to do with security or
safety
well the senate held its first hearing
today to probe what did happen on
january 6th and at that hearing senator
josh hawley asked the former u.s capitol
police chief steven sund
to respond what general honore has said
watch he's criticized you for
and i'm quoting now the appearance of
complicity
during the attack and also said that you
were potentially
undertook complicit actions those are
his words during the attack
mr sund were you complicit in this
attack on january 6th
absolutely not sir i've heard those
comments as well and i think it's
disrespectful to myself and to the
members of the
capitol police department it's an
outrageous thing to say or to suggest
particularly on the basis of zero
evidence but that's not the only norm
that's been shredded
in the wake of january 6. we learned
that the federal bureau of investigation
the fbi according to a piece in the
intercept sees
thousands of phone and electronic
records texts
belonging indiscriminately to everyone
around the capitol complex on january 6
and that includes
members of congress is that legal how
can it be legal they did it anyway
and the fbi apparently used emergency
powers that required no warrant
it's a remarkable story no one is
talking about this senator hawley joins
us tonight
to respond senator thanks so much for
coming on um so first
to your exchange over general honore
today
do you think this man who was an open
partisan and i would say a bigot
um and a conspiracy person could he take
the role that nancy pelosi has
designated him for do you think
this is absolutely outrageous tucker the
idea that he's going to lead a security
review this is a guy
who did what we've seen the liberals do
time and again he blamed the police
first
he has no facts he has no idea what
actually went on and he's out there
blaming the police and saying that
they're complicit that
they helped the rioters it's absolutely
outrageous but if you look at his
history
he has over and over again blamed law
enforcement
he criticized law enforcement who were
responding to rioters all last summer
including in portland and elsewhere
this is somebody who has no business no
business
leading a security review so the capital
city of the united states is still
occupied by the us military tonight no
one will make them leave or even demand
an explanation for why they're there
now we learn that the fbi took with no
warrant
stole effectively phone records from
members of congress
and anyone who was at the capitol that
day how can that be legal
i'm not sure that it is legal tucker and
i have to say it's unbelievable to read
this stuff in the press
this is the only way that members to my
knowledge at least and members of
congress are finding out about any of
this and once again
we've got the fbi going and doing this
stuff without oversight now listen
our law enforcement agencies should be
tracking down criminals
they should be bringing them to justice
they should be prosecuting them to the
fullest extent of the law
the issue here is and we've seen this
movie before
we've seen these law enforcement
agencies go way over and above and sweep
in
law abiding activity we've seen the
corporations get in on this act you
reported about bank of america
voluntarily apparently turning over
customers
personal data now we've got the telecoms
apparently turning over it's reported
the the messages cell phone data of
folks who we have no reason to believe
were anything other than law abiding and
this is really really frightening stuff
and to those who say we need a new
domestic war on terror
that will give even more unaccountable
power to these law enforcement agencies
without any kind of oversight
well that is a scary prospect and i'm
totally opposed to it
there needs to be real oversight here in
real accountability
i mean if the democratic party is trying
to create violent extremism
they're doing exactly what you would do
if you wanted to create it i mean making
people paranoid and crazy
people feel totally undefended and
afraid
will more republicans stand up and say
wait a second we want to you know what
are the troops doing here why is the fbi
stealing our text messages
will anybody push back other than you do
you think well i i sure hope so
you heard today at this hearing i mean
you heard at least one other member
senator rick scott
asked what what about all these national
guard troops thousands of them here
why are they here nobody had any answers
for him nobody could answer him
we still can't get any answers as
members of congress so this is there's
got to be real accountability there's
got to be real oversight
yeah it's starting to really scare
people it really is i think senator i
appreciate you coming on tonight
thank you thank